[Music]
hello it's been a while I know I'm not
gone I have just been extremely busy and
I know that I said I was going to be
extremely busy but even I underestimated
just how busy I was going to be
turns out filming a movie is kind of
hard and it takes a lot of time and
getting it started is uh one of the most
important parts of it so that's what
I've been doing
yeah
yeah but we're in a Groove and we got
caught up and I finally have some
breathing room so I wanted to update you
guys to tell you that no I did not ask
for a game suggestion list just to
ignore it again no it was not an
elaborate ruse just to cause anguish
amongst you no I am not just trying to
goof with you there are videos on the
way and the even sadder part of that is
that there have been videos that have
been ready since before I even left to
go film this movie I was just so busy
it's literally been we leave set I get
home and I pass out and then I wake up
and then I go immediately back to set
that's how intense it's been but
honestly like it's turning out
wonderfully I uh I can't wait to tell
you guys about it and it won't be too
much longer before you can get some
information about it uh but it's just
man it's been cool
it's been a whole new adventure it's so
wonderful to know that there's so many
things left for me to learn
um because with YouTube like I know it
very well and I know making Let's Plays
very well and I know how to make video
content on YouTube
um but crafting a story and trying to
really get into the weeds of how to make
this the best movie Possible Oh that I
can make not the best movie ever
obviously of a long way before that but
it's nice to know that there's like this
new mountain to climb right this is new
challenge to have there's a new set of
skills to build even after making heist
in space and all the other uh short
projects that I have
um to tackle something this big is
intimidating
and I like that feeling I like being
challenged that feeling that I've always
talked about before where I I wake up
and I want to do that thing and so on
today you know it's my day off which is
weird because I woke up and the first
thing I wanted to do was go to set and
be able to continue making the movie but
it's good to have a break because I am
going to be recording more videos this
weekend I have been keeping up with a
podcast which has been about the only
thing that I've been keeping up with so
if you haven't seen distractible now has
video episodes that you can find on
Spotify and go my favorite sports team
will have video episodes very soon those
podcasts are linked in the description
but also more videos are on the way I
know it's been an app since been a
little over two weeks now since the last
one
um and yes I have about a week's worth
of videos that I have not posted since
before I recorded and those will be
coming very soon including raft have not
had time to record sons of the forest
have not had time to record any of the
games that you have requested and I
think people misinterpreted when I said
I want to make dense little videos
basically I just meant give me short
games give me tiny games or give me a
series that you don't mind broken up
into like 10-15 minute chunks when I
said I was going back to the old ways of
Markiplier
I meant those days when I would hit
record and then I would stop hitting
record and I would directly upload from
the fraps file straight up into YouTube
and then I would be able to just uh go
on my Merry way and make a make a
thumbnail that's equivalent in Ms paint
and then I'd be I'll be off to the races
to like go back to set and I could
actually make things one of the most
humbling experiences about this is just
learning that I can't do everything
I know that sounds egotistical but
really with space you know I I
definitely did not do everything myself
there was a team of incredibly talented
people that were helping me and that's
no different this time but more than
ever I've needed to rely on the
expertise of the crew and allow them to
uh help make this thing a reality and
hopefully enjoy the process at the same
time because it's never easy to do
something like this and it's even harder
to do something like this when you know
you can make it even better than before
you could imply all the skills that
you've learned in the past and you can
put them forward towards this one and
then you can keep learning so that the
next one can be even better
and that's what the most exciting thing
about it is is that I still have more to
learn
and that's what's great about it that's
really what is great about it
um there's so many uh people that ask me
you know about how to start YouTube and
I often just say like just do it and I'm
finding
that it's the exact same principle for
going into any kind of higher quality
video production like making an
interactive series or making a movie or
a short film or whatever you kind of
just dive into it and you'll make a ton
of mistakes but so long as you don't let
your mistakes hold you back or try to
just bash your face into it without
adapting and changing and learning if
you just jump into it you're so
committed already that you can't back
out and you have to keep moving forward
and that is one of the best ways to get
better at something
commit to something that is more than
what you're capable of handling and
hopefully you have people that can
assist you on the way but if you got it
yourself you know you just do the best
you can
you just do the best you can it's how I
made the first sketch comedy with Wade
back when we made the fall of Slenderman
and I didn't know what we were doing and
we failed on the first time and then we
picked it back up and we said okay let's
try something else maybe we could just
do an interview maybe there could be a
character behind it maybe it could be
orph stash
and that's how that all came to be and
with this next project it's
it really is just
you just dive into it and you you let it
take you and you you you you just
I don't know you get lost in the process
and getting lost in the process can mean
that videos get lacking but it can also
mean it opens up your eyes to
Opportunities you never thought were
possible before I never thought that I
could do something like this I I'm so so
honored by all the incredibly talented
people that have decided to lend their
skills to the project and I I'm
I'm just so happy every day that people
are proud to be a part of it and people
are wanting to put their best foot
forward to wanting to apply it with the
best of their abilities and you know
that's the entire crew for this one the
entire crew has been humbling in the
amount of work that they've been willing
to put into something that was just
conjured out of my imagination and it
brought to life it's just like
I'm just really honored well the people
that have lent their skill to this one
and I just want to do them proud which
is why I work so hard at it and why I
want to show people that I'm just as
present as they are
um because that's another challenge to
try to match other people's you know
commitment to it
um
I could go on all day about that but I
won't either way
I have not been gone I've been
incredibly busy but now that we have
some breathing room now that I've gotten
through the first stages of it and now
that we have a rhythm and a flow and
we're getting really into it I think
that I can finally take a little bit of
time and you know make a few videos here
and there and try to keep up with a
regular schedule and keep you updated
about all these things that are
happening in the background
I know I made a commitment a while ago
that I was like going to be more
um upfront about things and be more open
and talk about it more openly but there
is something nice about the little
element of surprise and I think when you
see this
you are going to be incredibly surprised
at what we are making
I can't wait for you to see it
but before you can see it I have to keep
working on it so I'm going to do that
um continue giving me your suggestions
in the comments here uh but preferably
in the form of like short videos I know
the person that has been making the list
has been Bolding things and kind of like
saying something short if you have like
good games that are like 10 to 20
minutes long I want to know about them I
need to know about them I do not have
time to do the normal research
research that I do for these things but
you know
I would appreciate any and all help and
thank you for the help that you've given
and thank you for the patience and thank
you for watching
well
I haven't had videos to watch but you
will soon
and then
you'll have a movie to watch
and that
that's gonna be really fun
so thank you
and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye